I asked especially to introduce our
speaker today because he's a terrific
man I'll tell you I'm so grateful for
your being here the college is thriving
it's never been so healthy and never
been so besieged as it is right now I'm
just saying at the table we swim in the
academic ocean and that's polluted
waters and we make our way but it's a
dangerous time in the world and we thank
you for the blessings you give us and I
can tell you we're doing pretty well
you'll see the signs of it while you're
here now I say our speaker is a terrific
man he's actually a man of courage and I
am privileged to been able to understand
that and I can explain it to you he's
the chairman of Helmerich & Payne as was
his father before him and I think his
grandfather - it's the biggest oil
driller in the country and he ran the
company for a long time himself as CEO
while he ran it it went from 500 million
to 11 billion in sales
he has where'd he go he went to
Dartmouth and Harvard Business School so
he went to the wrong College and and his
five children and my mad and who are
tremendous people also went to the wrong
college a sore spot
between us but I'll tell you his story I
met him first on September 6 2002 I
looked all this up the price of oil on
that day was 28 dollars and 28 cents a
barrel since then it's been at 132 right
now it's at 96 the price is relevant
because he was about to do something
he was about to bet the company that two
generations before him had run on
something and it's a curious thing and
it's actually a moral thing more than
anything else I understand the story
because the first great Runner of a big
business I've ever met in my life was
the man named Henry Salvatori who helped
to invent the method by which we look
for oil the seismic method and Henry
Salvatori actually did the same thing
that this man Hans home Rick did in the
oil industry the oil service industry
there was a practice of charging by the
day and so if you send a team out to
look for oil you paid them by the day
and if you send a team out to drill for
oil you paid them by the day and of
course think what that sets up in the
way of interest it actually sets up a
conflict of interest between the
customer and the supplier because of
course you want to take a lot of days
and Henry Salvatore he got rich stop in
that practice radical thing to do bet
the company on it and on the day I met
Hans homewreck with his five young
children inheriting a big company but
not nothing nothing like it is now and
while selling it under 30 dollars a
battle barrel he was getting ready to
invent an entirely new kind of oil rig a
rig that could drill much faster and be
moved much faster than any that existed
and it was gonna cost a fortune and he
was going to stop charging by the day
and the reason is he was going to drill
faster which is of course against his
interest and that's why oil was being
drilled for in dilapidated old rigs that
took a month to move don't know if it's
gonna work he said and I said why are
you gonna do it and he said
this situation is not good we should fix
this I'm gonna try and if the old price
goes up we'll do really well if my rig
works flex rig is that what it was
called now since then I've met him many
times and I confess that I admire him
very much and also what fun he is and
we're gonna have a show of hands in a
minute whether he should join the
college board now that he's retired as
CEO of the company because he is one of
the best people in business I ever met
last time I saw him I went to his
headquarters in Tulsa and they've got it
down to this now you go in a room in
this big building in central Tulsa and
it's like war room there are these huge
screens up there and on every screen is
an oil rig and what it's doing right now
and there's engineers dozens of them
sitting in this room monitoring these
rigs now when you drill for oil you get
this guy who's never done anything else
in his life and he's an oil guy and he's
a great kind of guy and he's got to make
judgments all the time about how fast to
go and if he goes too fast the darn
thing broke blow up or something or
break and then you've got downtime and
you lose time and if you go too slow you
lose time and so it's a judgment deal
and this guy has decided that he was
going to turn that into the nearest
thing to science you could get and all
those engineers sitting in that room in
this war room and it's kind of like
going to Cheyenne Mountain to NORAD in
there they can run those rigs from there
and they can talk to the guy who's got
his hand on the throttle all the time
and he invested in that that cost a
fortune and nobody else had ever thought
of that and you know oil went up but the
revenues of his company
how many times is that they've gone up
22 times since he took it over and write
you think about this because by the way
this is I like to say we live our human
lives in the context of our families in
the context of making a living and in
the context of our faith those are the
places where we do the struggles that
human life is measured by and we all
live our lives in the same way they
unfold in time and we don't know what
tomorrow will bring and so very much of
what we do you choose according to
doubtful outcomes and you choose because
it just seems the right direction
and you're gonna try that because you
believe in it and you'll feel good if it
works and so many things are like this
particular case it's more risky to do it
this way
why do it now when everything is bad
when everybody's losing money when
everybody's laying stuff off when you've
got a stock price and they're gonna
watch how much money you borrow and
they're gonna watch your revenues like
crazy and they're gonna measure all that
quarter-to-quarter so as I say that we
meet here today not only a delightful
man but also a brave man Hans Hamrick
will you have an introduction like that
and then you ask yourself on your way up
is there any way I could just stay
seated
I was also caught up in the collective
disappointment when Larry came to the
podium I shared your disappointment on
Oh we just as soon hear Larry for the
next 30 minutes and then you are gonna
be stuck with a contract driller for a
little bit but I really appreciate Larry
those comments
I remember our time in my living room
when we had that conversation about
pricing strategy and how do you kind of
extract the value proposition from a
customer if you're bringing lots of
efficiency to bear and this kind of like
you heard he went into this very
thoughtful sequential logical approach
to what he would do and how he would
handle it and I thought boy what other
college president in the country could
you have this conversation with and I
questioned that there's another one out
there and then just to hear him talk
about work family and faith we've had
some success with with the Flex rig and
with the company but you know I've often
thought I would trade any success there
for success with my family and then
being able to have a faith journey that
is is honoring to the calling and so we
are similar in that respect all of us
have to cope with how we define success
and whether we put too much priority in
our careers and it becomes at the
expense of our walk of faith and our
relationships with our family so that's
been a priority that I don't want to
fail that well you guys are nice for
listening during lunch we had a great
day yesterday and oftentimes these
conferences
you know have a great start then the
lunch time guy is a little disappointing
you tolerate him and then it picks back
up in the afternoon and the evening and
then tomorrow is going to be a great day
so if that happens just know that's a
typical pattern don't don't have too
much disappointment around it a great
man that said that we live in terrible
this is a terrible and glorious time to
be alive I'm barring the course from dr.
Arnn
and it's true I think of the glorious
aspect of that for for our industry it's
been great to see just American
ingenuity we've played a very small part
in it and it's been fun to be part of
that right but what a great run the
American energy industry is engaged in
right now and it should be a source of
great national pride it should be
something I think historians will look
back and say my goodness they were
following this kind of trajectory of
depleting their reserves and and then
somehow in 2002 that was reversed out
and with in 1214 short years they became
the number one natural gas producer in
the world we're closing in on being the
number one oil producer in the world it
almost defies human logic to think that
the industry has enjoyed the type of
Renaissance that in fact we have just
just last 12 months we've added another
net million barrels to our production so
you got to think oh well declines and so
you have this wedge where you have to
just work hard on the hamster wheel to
stay even but but to net add the type of
gross production we've seen both on
guests and all have been just amazing
it's been glorious terrible terrible
because we have those that do oppose us
similar Larry to what you said about the
college we heard last night what a great
talk that was
from and I would I would love to well
I'd love to carry Larry around and do
introductions from now on but then I'd
like to have an accompany me because she
can say things that I have a difficult
time saying and getting out alive with
but her frustration with kind of the
environmental crazies that she talked
about I think is well-founded she she
talked about just the crusade they seem
to be on against this oil and gas
business against the progress that we've
made and how it's made
I loved how she talked about the
importance of energy and how we take it
for granted I love the picture of the
ambulance and the notion and it's true
and I've traveled in the world where you
don't know if the hospital is gonna have
power for the next 24 hours
and we take so much for granted she did
a great job of pointing that out and we
have this great blessing you remember
that the slide with all the shale
opportunities we have this unique
blessing in the United States and and so
it just is frustrating that we have
these zealots that seem so determined to
get really no cost to themselves to try
to pull that off reminders I liked Peter
Grossman's comments about over time the
government declaring these energy crisis
and then with no trust at all in free
markets you know the things that
Hillsdale students are hearing and
teaching and learning about with the
dynamics of a free market and capital
going to opportunities that reward risk
and provide a payoff for that that the
government just so misses that notion
and gets so intimidated by a notion of
scarcity that then as Peter described we
have these goofy policies and they're
counterproductive and they end up
driving results that are just the
opposite of what we would have hoped
John Serena and I were taking a tour and
I saw the Reagan's
that's you very well displayed on campus
and and I was remembering a story of and
I'll shorten it but having a chance to
go to the White House with my Oklahoma
senator who was chairman of the Energy
Committee Tom and it was in 81 and the
industry was a graveyard but but Reagan
got it and even though we were really
going kind of with this notion of golly
this this is a this is a very very
difficult time Reagan understood that
well you go through times like this and
it has a disruptive but cleansing effect
and he believed in free markets and the
industry is a lot better for it and he
understood and got that right you know
and had that slide who are these people
do you remember that and her slides by
the way are a lot better than mine I
remember the one with the gal or the
whoever it was I couldn't retail that
was afraid of hormones and milk and then
but the thought that came to my mind is
well who are they but then why do they
hate the business so much what is it
that makes them so radicalized against
the oil and gas business and the success
we have and I think it is a threat to
their utopian world of total renewable
energy driving a major economic power
Ford and being able to compete with
other major economic powers in the world
today this whole jobs war that our
children and grandchildren will be
engaged in it's difficult to after the
tens of billions of dollars Peter told
us since 92 that have poured into the
wind and solar subsidies it still
generates just under 3% of our
electrical power today so thank goodness
we've had the success we've had in the
oil and gas business now won't hurt some
of those folks because they'll still
drive the Volvo they'll still have the
double shot latte
expresso something hot showers in some
cases
but but they're able to preach against
it really at no cost but who it hurts is
the working man who it hurts is the
American worker who now has a chance to
have factories reap a tree is to the
United States it hurts the folks that
are paying for their heating bills
paying for energy and when they can get
it in a dependable way cheap they're
much much better off I'm going to take
you quickly through Larry did a better
job at this and these slides do so I'm
gonna accelerate some of the story but
what I want to do is tell you a little
bit just about the role we've played and
then kind of reflect for a second just
on some of the government involvement in
this well this is a good example every
time I give a talk I have this I won't
make you read it but it basically says
don't depend on anything I say it's a
forward-looking SEC requirement and it
says not to trust anything you may hear
in the rest of the presentation okay I'm
gonna run through this quickly we are
the largest land provider today we have
290 rigs running as as we speak we we
also have the largest highest and high
sir turns on Capitol on daily margins we
lead in kind of every known category we
have a chance to be in most of the major
basins from Bakersfield to Pennsylvania
from North Dakota to the tip of South
Texas we also have an international
presence that's smaller just because the
opportunity set is so great here we've
been able to have a great growth ramp
with really no net debt on our balance
sheet so it's it's been gratifying to be
able to keep a strong balance sheet in
the midst of growth Larry mentioned we
have 11,000 employees today this is a
deal that was formed by a handshake
between Bill Payne in my granddad in
1920 and then dad and I he started in
the company in 1950 was CEO in 1960
Kame CEO in 89 and as Larry mentioned
I'm now chairman and they found a
stronger smarter better-looking guy to
do the job that I was doing but I like
just mentioning the way a lot
better-lookin thank you
but John started on the rig floor and he
worked his way through school then got
his engineering degree he then turned
for us and and then instead of just kind
of taken the 3-4 months of being exposed
to our field operations which we really
require of all of our engineers all
these we were very engineering centric
we have several hundred engineers in the
company and instead of doing a rotation
which we require for every one John
stayed on and worked his way up through
the driller position and it becomes very
inspirational to our guys that follow
under his leadership now we've worked
together for 25 years and he's gonna do
a great job for us you know I show this
slide you've seen it the barometer in
the business is what the rig count
happens to be and you see where the
shale revolution begins on the far left
I like this slide because I remind
people when a drilling rig shows up it's
it's like a little factory it has 20
direct employees but then it has a
multiplier of several times of that and
so you think about rural America and
have an opportunity to attract five or
ten drilling rigs where the starting pay
is seventy thousand dollars for a floor
hand we've got a lot of ex-military a
lot of guys that just have their high
school education but understand hard
work understand how to do things that's
where our money is made we're very field
centric on what makes this business go
and so just seeing that the gray is the
overall recount we're we're in the blue
but I think the point of it is that this
is good for America Peter Grossman was
talking yesterday about when prices go
down you see that little dip gas prices
right before that were twelve dollars
and they went to $2 everyone redirected
their drilling rigs to oil
and the market without the government
helped so strangely is able to figure
out the go forward and had a slide like
this I kind of like church better but I
did want to put this up just because I
think it's important that folks
understand and what you can't really
show there you have to compress the
depth so our average vertical section in
a well today is over ten thousand feet
deep so all your aquifers are occurring
two hundred four hundred feet deep and
we are way way beyond where those are at
risk and as she mentioned there there's
been no there's there's been no proof of
water contamination in over a million
wells drilled that have been frack but
what I wanted to show you on this was
just the neat thing that happened along
the way in the energy revolution was
America's unique and not only do we have
like she mentioned the private royalties
where they're incentivized
to take the value especially in
producing formations or non commercial
formations that can become productive
what we had here was also the mapping if
you will of lots and lots of wells that
have been drilled so where you see that
well bore go horizontal we knew that
that formation existed is just
non-commercial it was kind of a junk
Rock so you'd put a piece of pipe there
it would be perforated but nothing would
come through so George Mitchell and
others figured out well we can design a
completion that allows us to frack into
that rock and allow it to flow and then
when you think about when you drilled
vertically through a junky semi
commercial pay zone and you only expose
your well bore to eight or ten feet of
it made it harder but if you could turn
and if you could go horizontal and if
you could run a lateral section where
you could expose half a mile a mile mile
and a half
of pay zone to that wellbore then that
well became very commercial and a real
barnburner they made a mistake it's been
missin aimed we should have come up with
something better than fracking we should
have some kind of term hydraulic Rock
therapy or some type of something with
massage in it or something but it's a
great breakthrough in terms of
completion technology and what we found
and and Larry was nice to talk about is
we had actually designed and built the
Flex rig prior to this and our notion
was we can just go vertically faster and
better and safer than anybody in the
business and we were going to make a
living doing that a nice thing happened
our customers wanted to build a curve
and then drill a thousand feet
horizontally and then five thousand and
then 10,000 and there just were no tools
to do that there were no drilling rigs
capable of doing that at the time except
the Flex rig and the race was on and we
began to build two and then three and
then four of those rigs a month I told
my wife we drove by an intersection in
town where they're putting up a new
stoplight and I think it's been six
months now and I said I can't understand
how we can build four flex rigs a month
and they fix them six months to put a
noose and I guess that's part of the
government talk that we're discussing
this this slide just talks about the in
the blue it just shows where the
business is going so today 80% of the
drilling activity now deals in a
horizontal effort and so it's really
just transformed the business this gives
you a picture if you if we have any
shareholders I didn't want them to be
disappointed that I talked without one
picture of the Flex rig so if you want
more pictures see me afterwards I'll be
happy to but we did introduce a tool
that was able to accomplish the
customers hire requirements and address
well complexity in these long laterals
and we not only designed it but we built
it I'll show you a slide on that this
this is another model that has had
capabilities that was the first in the
business to be able to drill on a pad so
when you think about the environmental
impact that that allows you to really
reduce by 80 plus percent the number of
locations when you can drill over 20
wells on a pad and you build it once and
then you slide it around and it reduces
the number of support and truck traffic
that's been a nice innovation this is
the flex 5 which is kind of now the new
flagship in the rig do you remember an
saying that baguette E and Hammer
museums there we've got one in Tulsa the
Gilcrease oh we should come visit but
that have been really supported by
energy money I love the idea of putting
an oil derrick in front of all of those
museums so I'm having our marketing guys
pursue that idea this just shows some of
the innovations that represent some of
our IP or Internet or proprietary and I
won't go through that with you except to
say it really has created a tool that is
over 50 percent better we're in the
Bakken she talked about being in North
Dakota when we arrived there four years
ago those wells on average were 50 days
now we've tripled the length of the
lateral and we're drilling those wells
in 16 days so that type of efficiency
capture creates huge value for the
customer I liked reading about even
though like you I shook my head when I
heard about Hillary Clinton talking
about business and corporations don't
add jobs and then our president you know
made the statement that you didn't build
that I'd love for him to come down to
green sport and we turn around where we
have 500 employees that take sheet steel
on one end and a finished completed rig
comes out on the other end and I think
it might do him some good
just to see that Americans really can
build things or our competitor went to
China to build their rigs we stayed here
not because we had government incentives
to do it but we liked the American work
ethic we like the well joints the
precision and the product that we
received and so it was something that
again paid off for us handsomely this is
what Larry and John saw that he
mentioned and we are able to kind of
read the dashboard of every rigged
real-time in the fleet and we drive a
lot of drilling optimization by being
able to support our field operations
this way it's a fun tour if you're in
Tulsa it's a it's a fun thing to show
often and see so be happy to have you
come look at that you know we get an
interesting I put this up just to say we
are in different countries in the world
we get a different lens on how different
governments treat their energy business
some much better than ours some worse
than ours we had 11 rigs nationalized in
Venezuela it's no longer on the map but
you know that's that's a government
energy policy gone gone bad in in spades
and remarkably with the second or third
largest oil reserves Venezuela imports
oil today and none of those rigs they
nationalize maybe one or two is working
today and you worry because that's a
real-world example where the government
becomes not only just a drag but a
threat to a thriving energy industry
this shows the growth ramp that we've
enjoyed I use this slide to say we know
how to build the iron we've been able to
have a nice organic growth ramp but what
makes this possible or the people behind
it and the mentoring and the training
and really the culture of the company
and the values that that we champion and
having guys that are willing to spend
their careers working with us and
helping us become
better we have a thousand employees with
over ten years experience we recognize
them at a dinner every year we have 475
that have been with the company over 20
years we have 70 that have been with the
company 30 years so it's that continuity
of effort and their willingness to help
us mentor and coach young people that
make that type of growth possible we're
proud of this as an industry we've
continued to do better and better in
terms of safety so what you're seeing is
a recordable or incident rate per 200
thousand man-hours worked this is one of
the areas where we have lots of
proprietary technology but this is one
of the areas we conduct multiple clinics
on and we'll get with competitors and
the customer and say here's what you can
do to make your safety better because if
we can share an idea or a technique or a
way to keep a young man from from danger
then we're happy to do that even still
we have a significantly better incident
rate than the industry this is a
comparative share price which at the end
of the day is our scorecard I like that
right before oil went from $100 to $80
but that's part of the business and we
can talk later about where that might
head ok that's a summary slide just on
some of the things that I think we do
well and have to do well to continue you
know one of the great things about a
free market is we've got guys chasing us
every day and we have people that get up
in front of investors and saying we're
trying to be the next time we're
campaign and so we wake up worried and
thinking about what makes it harder for
them to compete with us and how can we
do this better and it's a great part of
a free market I want to just make a
couple of comments because I want to
save maybe a couple minutes just for
some questions if you have any you know
no one's arguing for no government
regulation there's there's a playing
field and
an impartial judge and an approach to
the business that government has a role
in we'd like it to be clear we'd like it
to be timely and fair but I think it's
important you know to say that that no
one is saying hey let's just turn this
loose but it is a question of what is
the right balance here are the number I
know you can't read that as well as I'd
like here the number of agencies though
you get a feel for it federal agencies
one of the things Hillsdale students
learn is the Constitution was right when
it said let's empower the states and the
states do a great job in their role as
regulators of energy here's federal
agencies that are engaged in the
regulation not just of the energy
business but of fracking so you might
have a hard time seeing the Department
of Defense the Army Corps of Engineers
the Department of Transportation one of
my favorites is FEMA so if you have an
area that has flooded private land they
will compensate you for that flooding on
some goofy formula but one of the
provisos is you can never frack on land
that they've compensated you for so
FEMA's in the fracking business the
Coast Guard regulates the types of
fluids that might be transported
involved with fracking so it's
frustrating if you look at government
regulations from 1997 to 2012 the the
telephone book thick government regs
continue to grow during that time period
they grew 26% during the same time
period energy regulations grew 145
percent so if you didn't think anything
could outpace the speed of government
regulations being added you were right
except if you're in the energy business
we go 5 to 1 in terms of increased
regulations
the feds say the states aren't adequate
in their control or regulation of energy
and you know I could go through these we
won't take the time to do that those are
the top producing states and the
different types of requirements
permitting regulations compliance and
it's very comprehensive and so I would
argue today that they're better suited
they're closer to the people they
understand the farmers and landowners
and transportation and infrastructure
needs and they're the better player to
be involved in this I think they do it
in a pretty full comprehensive way you
know this is a slide that if you think
of the government as a fiduciary and a
steward of public lands to me it's
disappointing that 90% of all known gas
reserves on federal lands 92% of all
known oil reserves are off-limits to the
industry so we are fence road away from
even being able to explore and develop
energy on over 90 percent of federal
lands if you're offshore that number
Falls to 87 percent so thankfully we
still have the Gulf of Mexico but but
it's it's it's a frustrating aspect of
government intervention the real weapon
that we see all the time and customers
complain about and we just see the
terrible results of is government delay
permitting delay so only 6% of the BLM
permits that are by law required to be
completed in 30 days only 6% of those
are in fact completed their average time
is 229 days so the state of Colorado
which is a very fierce regulator they
are able to do it in 27 days Ohio 14
days North Dakota 10 days the average on
federal lands 229 days this is kind of a
proof in the pudding slide it shows oil
production on federal
and on top you see the increase on
non-federal lands so those are in
private hands and they're up nearly 30
percent on federal lands so when you
hear Obama talk about and and push his
way the head of the parade on how great
the energy business is doing the only
piece he's responsible for at a time
when you've had a 30% increase or the
bottom two lines and they've actually
dropped seven percent I don't have the
natural gas light up it's actually a
little bit worse natural gas on
non-federal lands is up forty percent
and on federal land down 23 percent okay
if I were a little bit more worked up
and we had a little bit more time I
would take longer to describe this nasty
business of Sue and settle I don't know
if you've read about it
google it it is really a fraudulent
abuse of government power and the way it
works is you have a top job at the EPA
Thomas Eyre Steyr hires you at one of
his high-dollar environmental groups in
that new position you sue your old
buddies at the EPA or at the Fish and
Wildlife and instead of working through
that in a good-faith manner they rush to
the table to settle and in the
settlement they agreed to these onerous
requirements that both sides secretly
want to impose on the oil and gas
business then insult to injury is they
agree in the settlement for the
environmental group to have its legal
fees paid for so between 2000 and 2009
the Sierra Club was in a hundred and
ninety four lawsuits against the EPA and
received 19 million dollars
reimbursement on their legal fees you
know it's just a travesty and I think
it's a huge violation of the proper role
of government
it's actually worse I could give you
lots of examples I'll reference you to a
great article if you're interested in it
this is a quote that I like and I like
that Larry at the table was talking
about Aristotle and his his take on this
is that the rule of law that the law
should govern and those in power should
be servants of that law but that's not
what we have today we have regulators
particularly with the leadership of the
white house abusing this position and
attacking an industry that I think is
very important that it succeeds and
helps us differentiate ourselves in our
competitive efforts in the world it's
fun for me to be on campus and to see
what a beacon Hillsdale is in a
real-world argument that has real
consequences to each one of us and to
know that students are being taught
respect for free markets the rule of law
constitutional rights now we need Larry
for them to be sent forth and correct
some of these ills
thank you very much I've enjoyed being
with you
thank you Matt I think we have a couple
minutes and you guys give me the timeout
sign but if you have any questions or
are there things that you like I'm gonna
be around for time - I'm happy to grab
you in the hallway hunt you talk about
the gerbils when oil went from 80 to 100
do you remember when it went from 4 to
30 that was when we really had a
exuberance in the oil industry yeah he
was talking about when oil prices went
down before I can remember
I should have framed it the cover the
Economist magazine and it said $5.00 oil
I don't know if you guys remember that
but that's about when Larry maybe that
was a little after Larry did his visit
he asked me how I sleep and I said I
sleep like a baby I sleep for a couple
hours wake up cry go back to sleep for a
couple hours so no it's it's but this
Peter Grossman said that that is part of
the greatness is the cyclic allottee is
you know in the seeds of high prices are
corrective forces that bring about less
demand and it's a self-correcting
mechanism and so what we would like you
know I think about showing the slides of
some of the things our guys have been
able do at the company and I think
energy department has over 20,000
employees a ploy ease tens and billions
of dollars but where they might have
shown up and helped was in some of the
things we talked about but thankfully
they weren't around and so our guys
designed the rig we did the training
there are 45 federal training programs
thankfully none of them got in our way
and well you know my sentiments okay
other questions
well thanks everybody enjoy the rest of
your time okay sure wait world waking up
to the horizontal drilling that we're
doing in this country well they're
certainly interested in it we're sending
ten rigs down to Argentina there's a neo
can play that's a world-class
unconventional shale play and Argentina
is a mess and they need our help and
they need our customers help to exploit
that opportunity the US has some great
advantages I might have touched on one
is you have this grand mapping of
subsurface strata that you know you can
go revisit other countries don't have
that we just have a great infrastructure
of support that makes this effort work
better and the private royalty mineral
ownership is a big driver so it is slow
it will be slow you have if you think
our environmentalists are crazy go over
to Europe and talk to the ones in Paris
they're holding up some great potential
there it's a crazy world out there you'd
think that with with the role Russia's
plan that the poles and and the other
perspective unconventional gas plays
would get more traction than they're
getting made this good question yes sir
in the business of oil drilling who is
your customer okay our job I could have
been clearer about this we really show
up and drill the wellbore and so our
biggest customer today is oxy followed
by Continental so it's the big shale
players marathon Chevron I we tend to
have the the majors that appreciate our
best-in-class safety and performance but
they're the customer and we turn over
that wellbore we get off of the location
Halliburton or slumbers a shows up with
the pressure pumping with the completion
services and then they
do the well completion we end up being
about 30% of the AFV well cost so we
play a smaller role in providing that
kind of overall service does that answer
your question okay
thank you I used to work in the power
industry field and we dealt a great deal
with government bureaucracies each one
of these bureaucracies is headed by a
little dictator who requires all of his
people to agree with what he wants it's
kind of like having all of your
employees in a swimming pool that's
filled with liquid manure all the way up
to their nose and if and if the leader
says as I've noticed on i-94 we need to
put up some signs because we haven't
done anything recently so we'll put up
signs telling people how long it takes
to go from Kalamazoo to Jackson and one
of his members might say well it's 49
miles and they're driving 60 it's going
to take them about 50 minutes and one of
the other guys taps him on the shoulder
and says don't make any waves they're
standing in manure up to their nose
don't make any waves I'm familiar with
that swimming pool yeah
so I found this fun but maybe I'm a geek
why is AC current better than DC current
describe that yeah okay I've got guys
that explain this a lot better than I do
but
so there were three phases of power or
chapters in the in power of a drilling
rig one was diesel mechanical and
there's still 350 diesel rigs out there
today then then they figured out we are
an early converted to SCR diesel
electric where you are doing direct
current and then the AC power is really
superior in lots of ways Larry it is a
smaller footprint has about 30% of the
moving parts it keeps you from you can
it has great torque characteristics and
that you don't burn up a motor by
bringing the power way down it also just
is a much better platform for lots of
automation and better controls so you
know we're able to overlay lots of
system controls lots of automation to a
drilling rig we can take a caterpillar
engine and get 45 different readouts in
terms of remote diagnostics
understanding that we actually
understand it better and cat does I've
met with their head of technology and
our guys uncrate a cat engine and they
replace it with eight parts that we've
had customized because we know they're
prone to fail in the field and they're
not as robust as they should be and I
was explaining this to Kat and saying
you know we have eight hundred and
eighty of your engines and it was a gal
and she said well you're really not one
of my top 50 customers I said okay well
understand and and I walked away
thinking it's better because our
competitors are just getting the normal
cat engine out of the crate
Thanks yeah we did we did so thankfully
we've got a lot of smart guys working
over there and hey this has been a lot
of fun for me thanks for your attention
I appreciate being here very much
thank you again Hans he's given me
permission to call him Hans so I feel
honored thank you for that wonderful
speech directly after the luncheon here
over in the lecture space will be an
antidote to the common core the Barney
charter school initiative and that will
be a roundtable with dr. copelan Rebecca
and Rebecca Fleming from the network
here in the college please enjoy your
afternoon and we'll see you back here at
4 o'clock for the afternoon speech thank
you